The key to figuring out which pieces of information we care about is to keep in
mind what we're looking for in the problem. Since we want to find out how much
one set of wiper blades costs to make, the total amount of money that Grant has
spent on micro productions so far, definitely matters, as does the total number
of wiper sets that, that money, $598, funded. Grant's lunch with his friends
does not affect the materials that he needs for a set of wipers, so I'm not
going to check this one off. It doesn't actually matter for this problem. And
this last choice that we have left to consider has to do with nozzles alone, not
wipers, and as you can see from the question, wipers are what we're concerned
with. We can tell already from this list, and from the fact that half of the
answers aren't checked off, that a lot of the times situations that pop up are
full of information that isn't relevant to the problem we're trying to solve.
And the first step to solving problems is to make sure we identify what we need
to pay attention to and what we can ignore, to make our lives easier.